A "Kraven the Hunter" movie is finally on
the prowl.
Sony has debuted the first trailer for the
newest entry in its line of Spider-Man related
films, so it's time to track down all the
movie connections and comic nods on this flick's trail.
In the comics, Kraven powers up with a special
herbal cocktail that boosts his physical attributes
far beyond normal.
While the upper limits of his strength are
by no means at Spider-Man's level, he can
definitely hold his own against many other
superpowered folks strength-wise.
Live-action adaptations of comic book characters
might not always share the exact power set
of their print counterparts, but from the
looks of it, Taylor-Johnson's Kraven will
be roughly as fast, agile, and powerful as
the comics one.
In the trailer, we see him chase a car that's
attempting to speed away in reverse, then
jump on top of it and tear his way in.
The superhuman feats on display seem to be
roughly in the same ballpark as the character's
traditional powers, and since the trailer
also makes clear that Kraven has greatly enhanced
senses, we just might be looking at a very
faithful adaptation ... at least, in this
particular respect.
While the trailer suggests that Kraven's powers
are similar to the comic book version, the
way he acquires them seems to be pretty far
removed from what fans are used to.
Instead of the herbal serum that gives him
powers in the comics, the implication here
seems to be that Kraven gets his power boost
from lion blood.
As young Kraven hunts a lion with his father,
he hesitates to fire his weapon, and the animal
mauls the boy.
As the injured Kraven lies on the ground,
a drop of the lion's blood falls in one of
his open wounds, jump-starting something that
seems to revive him and give him superpowers.
An accidental blood transfusion with a large
cat seems like an odd origin story, to say
the least.
It seems that the trailer is deliberately
missing a few steps in the process, possibly
to avoid revealing major plot points.
Or hey, maybe the lion just happens to be
radioactive.
It's clear from the initial trailer that "Kraven
the Hunter" is leaning hard into the family
drama element of its titular character's backstory,
and it seems his father isn't the only blood
relative he'll be at odds with.
Indeed, audiences get their first peek at
Kraven's half-brother Dmitri, a character
far better known for his alter ego as Spider-Man
supervillain The Chameleon.
In the trailer, fans learn that the character
doesn't approve of his half-brother's brutal
quest for justice, indicating that he may
have stronger moral fiber than his comic book counterpart.
While the trailer doesn't include a look at
the Chameleon's trademark skills as a master
of disguise, reports from Deadline and other
outlets indicates that the character delves
headfirst into the persona at some point in
the movie.
Of course, "Kraven the Hunter" is already
dealing with a laundry list of antagonists,
so it remains to be seen just how extensive
of a role the face-changing villain plays
in this film.
In any case, viewers would do well to second-guess
whether certain characters are really themselves
on-screen, or if it's Chameleon impersonating
them.
If there's one Spider-Man villain with an
exceptionally spotty track record in cinema,
it's the Rhino.
This behemoth of a foe has appeared a few
times in various movies, with a version portrayed
by Paul Giamatti briefly popping up in "The
Amazing Spider-Man 2" and a couple of multiversal
variations getting cameos in "Spider-Man:
Across the Spider-Verse."
But audiences haven't really gotten a chance
to see the character rise as a legitimate
villainous threat.
However, the first trailer for "Kraven the
Hunter" indicates that the movie may be giving
him a bigger spotlight this time around — along
with, on some level, returning him to his
comic book roots.
The final moments of the trailer introduce
audiences to Alessandro Nivola's take on the Rhino.
Though viewers don't get to see him go full
beast-mode, they do witness him activate his
powers by way of a self-applied injection,
giving him his signature tough gray armor.
This sequence shows a Rhino a bit closer to
the original comics conception rather than
the giant robot suit that Giamatti wore in
"The Amazing Spider-Man 2."
While the trailer's Rhino tease may have fans
chomping at the bit for more, it's wise to
temper expectations on how many superpowered
shenanigans the character will actually get up to.
In an interview with The Hollywood Reporter,
Nivola said that he only transforms at the
very end of the film.
Based on his quote, it seems that this scene
may actually come from the film's conclusion,
thereby setting a full-fledged Rhino up for
a "Kraven the Hunter" sequel.
Sony's Marvel movies have generally delved
into darker and more graphic subject matter
than their Marvel Cinematic Universe equivalents,
but the films have nonetheless remained firmly
rooted in PG-13 territory.
That's what made it rather surprising when
Kraven actor Aaron Taylor-Johnson revealed
at CinemaCon 2023 that "Kraven the Hunter"
would land a strong R-rating.
Fans may have had their doubts, but the trailer
definitively puts any skepticism on that front
to rest.
Throughout the trailer, audiences see Kraven
take out a number of hired henchmen in spectacularly
gory fashion.
Throats are sliced, necks are stabbed, and
chests are shot through with crossbows.
The lead even bites off part of a guy's face
at one point, just to really hammer the point
home that, yes, "Kraven the Hunter" isn't
pulling any punches with its bloody brand
of violence.
Oh, and the trailer shows a young Kraven getting
mauled by a lion, so toss graphic child peril
on the list of "definitely-not-PG-13" stuff
in here, too.
Most movies adapted from comic books alter
things here and there to adjust the property
from the page to the screen.
Sometimes, in the interest of telling a good
story, writers and filmmakers will alter the
origins or setting of a character.
In this case, the writers went a bit further,
and appear to have fundamentally altered the
core motivations of the character.
In the trailer, we see that Kraven is hunting
for one reason.
"My father puts evil into the world.
I take it out."
Since this is an origin story, we can assume
this mostly occurs before he turns into the
brutish hunter hellbent on catching his most
pursued prey, Spider-Man.
However, in the comics, Kraven is a depraved
man beaten in childhood by his alcoholic father
and who, in turn, beats his half-brother.
He turns to big game hunting and downs every
coveted animal on his list before turning
his attention to Spider-Man.
Since the superhero represents the animal
that haunted his dreams since his mother's
time in an asylum, it becomes a personal mission.
While there are shreds of that origin represented
in the trailer, like his father as a villain,
being tormented by spiders, and so on, the
film seems to be taking the anti-hero approach
to the famous Spider-Man antagonist.
Is Kraven destined for a showdown with Spider-Man?
That remains to be seen, but the trailer for
his upcoming solo movie does tease the hunter's
obsession with the friendly neighborhood superhero.
Toward the end of the teaser, Kraven is shown
lying on the ground as spiders rush toward
him from the trees.
The sequence might help to remind viewers
that this is a "Spider-Man" Universe movie,
but it might also reveal more about Kraven's
psyche.
The scene is clearly done in homage to Marvel's
"Kraven's Last Hunt" storyline.
This tale chronicles the titular villain's
attempts to dispose of Spidey and take his
place, and it's widely regarded as one of
the best stories in "Spider-Man" history.
Furthermore, the scene in the trailer is a
reference to "Web of Spider-Man #31," which
features a panel that depicts Kraven munching
on arachnids as they cover his entire body.
Is the "Kraven the Hunter" trailer trying
to tell us that this version of the character
will also be hell-bent on eating Spider-Man
down the line?
With a piece of Venom's symbiote now in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe alongside Peter
Parker, anything is possible.
While it hasn't officially been confirmed
yet, seemingly everyone knows that Ariana
de Bose is set to play Calypso in "Kraven
the Hunter."
However, if there are still any lingering
doubts about that fact, the teaser should
clear them up.
In the comics, Calypso is a voodoo priestess
and Kraven's love interest.
She takes great delight in nurturing his psychopathic
tendencies and fueling his hatred of Spider-Man
to a troubling extent, so at least they've
got hobbies in common.
However, if Sony insists on turning Kraven
into a sympathetic antihero for his big on-screen
outing, it makes sense to give Calypso a more
lighthearted makeover as well.
The trailer implies that de Bose's character
will be on the protagonist's side, which only
lends credence to the rumors that she's playing
some version of the voodoo priestess.
Furthermore, Calypso often sports a gold necklace
around her neck — similar to the one de
Bose wears in the "Kraven the Hunter" trailer.
While it was impressive when the studio booked
Aaron Taylor-Johnson for the "Kraven the Hunter"
lead, Sony also locked in another compelling
name from the indie film realm for a potentially
major supporting role in Christopher Abbott.
Abbott's role has yet to be confirmed, but
rumors abound he's playing Spidey foe The Foreigner.
Perhaps best known for roles in HBO's "Girls,"
and the 2019 mini-series "Catch-22," Abbott
has also wowed in projects like "It Comes
At Night," "First Man," and "Possessor."
"Kraven" is undoubtedly his biggest film to
date, and if Abbott is playing the Foreigner
in the blockbuster, he'll no doubt bring something
unique to the mix.
Fans would probably not call the Foreigner
a major Spider-Man baddie; he's probably best
known for once being married to fellow mercenary
Silver Sable.
But minor villains have gotten big movie roles
in the past.
C-lister The Spot was the key villain in "Across
the Spider-Verse," after all.
It remains to be seen how big a role the Foreigner
might play in "Kraven the Hunter."
After giving a look at Kraven's origin, most
of the trailer is dedicated to showing how
many different people the grown-up version
of Sergei can kill.
But one element of the character sticking
out like a sore thumb is Sergei's manner of
speech, because he appears to have an American
accent.
That shouldn't be the case, given that his
entire family is Russian, a detail that's
been preserved from the comics, as we hear
his father speak in a Russian accent multiple
times during the first half of the trailer.
"Power is about strength.
If you show weakness, you will give our enemies
an opening."
Perhaps Kraven was shipped off to a boarding
school, where one could assume he picked up
his American accent.
If that's the case, it's unclear whether he
was shipped off to the boarding school before
or after the accident that gives him his powers,
but by the time he's a teenager, Sergei's
speech is clearly not with a Russian accent.
"She died because you sent her away."
"Kraven the Hunter" is the next chapter of
Sony's Spider-Man-less Spidey-Verse, so it
makes sense for there to be some connections
to "Venom" and "Morbius."
The trailer does seem to connect to one unseen
character first mentioned in the first "Venom."
A man enters an office to see Mr. Taglin.
Unfortunately, Kraven's already killed Mr.
Taglin and shoots the man with a crossbow.
It certainly seems like Mr. Taglin was important…
"Mr. Taglin?
Mr. Taglin.
Where's Mr. Taglin?"
Another Taglin was referenced in "Venom."
In that movie, Lee Taglin is an employee at
Michelinie & McFarlane who works with Anne
Weying, Eddie Brock's ex-fiancée.
This is the law firm that represents the foundation
responsible for capturing the symbiotes, one
of which was Venom.
It's possible that the Mr. Taglin whom Kraven
killed is the same one who worked with Anne.
After all, why focus on the name so much?
Or perhaps it's someone who's related to Lee
Taglin, or an entirely different person.
Either way, a connection certainly seems likely,
especially given how often the name is mentioned
in the scene.